all right it is my honor to introduce
our next speaker Joan ferrini Mouton d
she and I were just chatting dr. Freda
Mundy is the assistant director of the
NSF foundation for education and human
resources she has had a multi-decade
career in education and making sure that
smart kids get even smarter working
especially in mathematics which I really
care about because I just tried to teach
my son some calculus and he now hates me
so very very interested in in Jones
thoughts on the way forward Joan thanks
very much I think he said this was the
fun-filled slot for the afternoon it is
that time you know but I'm just
delighted to be here and I'd like to
thank subra for the opportunity to be at
this event certainly congratulations to
to the founders of the Global Learning
Council and for the great promise that
that organization holds I think for for
making a difference internationally in
the state of learning and that's a tall
order and an exciting and important line
of work to take on I'd also like to
thank presidents Suresh and Gallagher
for this event and for the opportunity
to to get to meet and learn from so many
people that I have admired over my own
career as I've watched the work in the
learning sciences that's gone on here in
Pittsburgh in both institutions and have
have been impressed by the way it's
beginning to accumulate and make a
difference and so in many ways it's just
it's a wonderful pleasure to be here and
I'd like to talk to a little bit today
again about about the promise of a
strong focus on learning internationally
and the opportunity that that provides
and then tie that to work that we are
doing at the National Science Foundation
and the priorities that we have in
particular in the Education and Human
Resources Directorate and offer both
some some quick snapshots of what i feel
is our indicators of great progress
but also to highlight what I would say
our challenges or opportunities and
where I'm trusting that this is the
community that can can take those on in
partnership with the National Science
Foundation and other organizations so
let's see okay this is in a very high
tech kind of place not clear to me where
we are down arrow is not working sorry
Big Chill someone in technical support
can help us I know we do have to do this
but try this
nope yeah we got it okay sorry okay so
first a couple of pieces of data that
are not unfamiliar to this group but
that that highlight I think the nature
and scope and severity really of the
challenges that we face coming from the
from the NMC horizon report one that
forty percent of global youth are
unemployed and to that the increase in
global higher education attendance is
expected to increase twenty five percent
over the next 12 years these are
stunning figures in that they indicate
the the potential reach of great
solutions to learning questions and to
learning challenges and the potential
for doing good for the world by solving
these sorts of problems so the global
research council has an important role
to play and keeping the global view in
in view is really quite important to all
of it as well as you think about
learning and this is a version of a
graph that gets used quite a lot around
the National Science Foundation this
particular version comes from the life
center which is one of the NSF funded
science of learning centers at the
University of Washington stanford and sr
I it basically depicts in orange well in
light blue what you see is the amount of
time people spend in waking hours which
seems to be conservative it says 16 but
as i watch teenagers around the world it
may be that they spend more wake waking
hours being able to learn and so anyhow
if you look at waking hours then you
look in orange that's the percentage of
time spent in formal schooling and then
in blue is the rest and so the
opportunity for learning inside of
school outside of school what what these
folks call lifelong and life wide
learning is something that all of you I
think have have been well aware of it's
just that now we can be more systematic
in taking advantage of this life wide
learning and probably need to be in the
design of our educational and learning
opportunities for for worldwide
improvement
so unpacking the questions that are
driving this symposium you asked two
questions or there were two questions
that that were in the materials you know
first what is the role of the learning
sciences in producing learning gains
there's a lot in there to be thinking
about and I think there's even a
reciprocal question which is as we
understand more about learning gains and
when they happen and when they don't how
does that feedback into our thinking
within the learning sciences always
being mindful that we need to keep
working with these cycles and then
secondly the role of big data in the
service of better learning another
fascinating question and I think if we
add to that this lifelong and life wide
notion then we get a whole series of
ways of thinking about things at
different stages in different settings
in different contexts this concept of
context mattering has come up repeatedly
through this meeting in oops sorry
something a little bit wrong in the
transfer of the slide but imagine there
to the left that it says the word
research on the left hand side of the
circles or of the arrows and I wanted to
convey to the group those of you who
have been familiar with the funding
patterns in the Directorate for
Education and Human Resources over the
over the decades have seen a strong push
by us to to balance our development or
curriculum development the building of
models within institutions or
programmatic designed programmatic
activities we tried to balance that with
a much stronger focus on research and to
depict that in a cyclic way so that we
can see that when we have research
questions and people in this room are
doing this work they guide and inform
the development of interventions and
attempts at improvement and then the
effective work with those interventions
takes us back into new research
questions and this cycle continues and
that's important to all of the work as
we go forward the Directorate is working
right now with three major thematic
emphasis and I think they apply well to
the work that you all are doing and I'd
like to try to use them to frame the
rest of my remarks and think about
challenges and opportunities as well as
great progress the Directorate that I
that I lead is large and dispersed
across all of the areas of science
technology and
and mathematics that is stem across
pre-k through gray and in school and out
of school we have programs that fund all
of these areas and so to try to find a
way to organize and frame that large and
wide set of investments we've been
working with these three ideas the
concept of focusing on stem learning and
stem learning environments and all of
the kinds of investments that go with
working to improve those two areas as
well as to understand them more fully
the second big focal area is stem
professional workforce preparation a
major a major issue of course for the
for the country and also a major
research issue because we have large
investment in the preparation of the
workforce and so to do that
strategically and do it well we want to
be sure that we're learning all that we
can about how to do it well and then
finally broadening participation in stem
bringing into the stem pathways and
pipelines people from groups that have
not been well represented in stem people
from underrepresented minority groups
people who are women people with
disabilities people of low socioeconomic
status people who've been isolated
geographically we are very concerned
with making sure that our investments
have a broadening participation
commitment as a part of what we do so I
think now what I'd like to do is say
just a little bit about about my take on
the learning sciences community the the
technology enabled learning work that
has been evolving over over a long time
and with so much of this work centered
in Pittsburgh actually to point out what
I see has some promising developments in
these three areas and then talk about a
little talk a little bit about the
challenges that I see so first of all
this is an arena where there are some
examples of applying findings from
research to actual instructional design
through the instructional design
principles that can capture and his team
have proposed and in other ways so we
really do have a nice case within the
technology world of looking at how
research can inform development and then
how that development can feed back into
the research and we probably need to
have some explanation of how that
happens as an illustration for other
domains also the the rapid testing the
a/b trials the multiple RCT is being
conducted we've heard quite a bit about
that it allows us to to test insights
from learning theory or to answer
questions my own recent experience at
taking a MOOC and I won't say which one
or who the who the professor was because
that would probably not be fair but I
just I so wanted to call him and say you
need to do an RCT right now on this
particular hypothesis that you have
because you're making too many claims
and I'm not sure that the students who
are in the discussion forums are
actually buying it but I will get back
to him later eventually you know the
notion that we can not only test
questions that come up as they as they
emerge but also that it can be a way of
testing theory I think needs to be noted
the availability now quantitative
approaches to cognitive task analysis
allows for the potential of much more
personalization of learning for
customization of the ways in which tasks
are are adapted for students and this
takes us well beyond the very time
consuming qualitative approaches and
again a huge advance for the field and
then finally the developments in theory
generation and application the ways in
which communities that work on data
mining are coming together with
communities that are our theory oriented
relative to learning and finding ways to
combine their questions all of these
seem to be promising NSF has funding in
all of these kinds of areas and this is
terrific at the same time there are lots
of challenges and I've just picked one
we've been hearing challenges all day
long and so we could have many others
here but the one that I wanted to
mention has to do with the continuing
need for measures and measurements
including performance assessments that
go beyond the cognitive assessments that
were more familiar with to the non
cognitive social and soft skill
indicators and we heard a little bit
this morning about this notion of middle
skills jobs and middle skills
development that's a very important
economic focus for the nation right now
and there are lots of tools that help us
at least get the lists of what these
skills might be now figuring out how to
them well and how to build those into
technology enhanced learning
opportunities i think is obviously of
interest to many but we will need more
to work on it one resource is this
national academies report education for
work and life that outlines advanced
knowledge and skills that are needed in
a variety of careers across three
different domains cognitive
intrapersonal and interpersonal and so
here you see the list and there's great
unevenness and how readily we can
measure these kinds of skills so
measuring intellectual openness
measuring communication responsibility
conflict resolution and so forth this
opens up a great set of opportunities
for researchers to begin to embed those
kinds of measurements in in the work as
far as the stem professional workforce
goes there are a number of promising
developments there as well the notion
certainly of portable and stackable
credentials as great opportunities for
workforce development many many examples
and they they intersect with the work
that we were hearing about here today
and could hear more about I know but
this seems to me to be a very ripe area
for continued focus NSF is quite
interested in at one of the examples
that that I wanted to use is a welding
some simulator produced by the weld the
ed advanced technological education
center where students are able to learn
the craft of welding before they have to
actually interact with a real with real
welding apparatus and these kinds of
learning opportunities of course heavily
used by the military very successfully
for a long time are now making their way
into wider educational use and their
potential for enabling people to come in
and out of STEM careers over the pathway
of their of their professional life it
seems to be quite strong and so seeing
more work in that area would be great
related to that is continuing
exploration of how badges and other
credentialing tools can motivate and
enable learning in interesting ways that
of course opens up into how do those
then linked to formal schooling and how
can they become integrated with the ways
in which teachers in K
through 12 schools or undergraduate
arenas are working and we're seeing some
work in that arena as well and then also
how can how can we be thinking about Big
Data not so much big data about learning
but big data from other arenas of
science becoming more accessible and
more available now to many students so
that their opportunities to learn new
and different science earlier in their
careers or in different depth might be
made possible and there are lots of
examples of that in astronomy in
genomics right here at Pitt Sam Donovan
and his team have been working with the
Rocky Mountain Biological Laboratory
which is one of NSF funded long-term
ecological research centers to use data
in undergraduate education and so again
I think some of some of the some of the
work that's happening in more basic
learning science and technology can now
be moved be moved into a more applied
arena as we think about helping
undergraduates connect to cutting-edge
science in front to your work there are
continuing challenges there have been a
number of reports in recent years about
the importance of preparing graduate
students in science for careers beyond
academia and the importance of making
sure that they get experiences in their
graduate training that will enable them
to have professional choices and
opportunities beyond academic positions
and so there are lots of efforts to
provide provide internships and
apprenticeships and models we're
graduate students PhD students in stem
fields get to go and work in government
and in industry to have authentic
experiences but to be able to imagine
those happening virtually happening in
very creative ways with cutting-edge
data with a possibility of enabling
those students to be making scientific
discoveries with data in a very broad
way I think is worth exploring related
to this would be the notion of
undergraduate research experiences we
heard earlier from subra I think the
problem about attrition in undergraduate
STEM fields with only forty percent of
those students who start actually
finishing one research finding would
suggest that if those students have
access to a research experience
early on in their career as freshmen or
sophomores that can make a difference in
their retention excuse me to do that at
scale would mean imagining a variety of
very creative and innovative virtual
solutions course based research another
very interesting trend would suggest
that we would like to see more ideas
about how to engage students with
authentic research as a part of their
day-to-day coursework we could say more
about the same for teachers I did want
to comment here on the challenge of
building developmental trajectories over
the career and it's a little bit related
to the how can we track learners across
their experiences and across there
across the years but this notion of
designing in pathways from novice to
expert experience within the learning
opportunities i think is important
broadening participation we also see
promising developments there through
through citizen science opportunities
and crowdsourcing ways of enabling all
students to have access to to learning
and to communities of learners through
data collection analysis and
communication of science we also can
begin to test the question about whether
diversity is an asset we make that
assertion there is some research to
suggest this as the case and we actually
can see some examples say unfold it were
people from very very different
backgrounds and perspectives have been
able to contribute the challenges with
broadening participation excuse me also
are quite serious we face the digital
divide issues we've talked quite a lot
already about privacy and intellectual
property issues motivation and relevance
how do we determine what will motivate
which groups of students and what will
keep them engaged and the affordability
questions I'll just sort of wrap up with
a few thoughts about areas that we would
like to explore more fully and this is
partly of course the Directorate for
Education and Human Resources but we
have colleagues all over the building
who are deeply interested in these
questions the questions of data sharing
and curation for wider research use is
of course of great interest to us
building the
expert data science workforce is
something we're interested in to given
that the agencies concerned with the
stem workforce and we've called for
proposals for building graduate
traineeship programs for data enabled
science and engineering enabling these
interdisciplinary and multidisciplinary
collaborations and providing the
preparation that folks might need to
move into those sorts of collaborations
and then we've talked quite a lot here
already about building building
innovations that can be used at scale
and implementing evidence-based
practices I just want to reaffirm that
we are quite interested in these areas
and if you don't find a solicitation
that says directly we would like to
study X Y or Z just know that you have
some flexibility with us and you can
find ways to get these ideas onto the
table Tom mentioned this morning the
notion of engaging teachers in
generating some of the research
questions and I think similarly
instructors at the university level if
they are part of helping to frame
questions we begin to move a little bit
toward this notion of everyone a
learning engineer I guess and then as we
imagine teachers and instructors using
these new techniques using these new
approaches where we will have
modularized versions of things where
people can pick pieces and adapt and
combine in interesting ways think about
the kind of support that beginning
instructors might need to do that well
and how do they make those choices well
and then also to think about the ways in
which technology and big data could help
us understand teaching more fully people
who do research on teaching often gather
data using video and so there are bodies
of video their collections of video of K
through 12 teaching in many many labs
around the country some major projects
that have collected a massive amounts of
video and yet we still don't have a
fully automated approach to using those
video data although there are certainly
efforts in that direction but the
potential to understand teaching better
is quite significant it's also possible
and I think there hasn't been much
discussion of this here yet but I think
there could be of thinking about how the
availability of technology now could let
but let instruction address different
content than it currently addresses I
mean we sort of we talk about the core
the common core and we talk about the
next generation science standards and
that's all terrific but I don't think
we've tested the limits yet of what's
possible for students to learn given the
availability of technology-enabled
learning and big data so now with the
ice cube experiment that's embedded in
the South Pole ice and funded by NSF
students could probably get a much
clearer idea of what a neutrino is at an
earlier age there are topics in genetics
where hands-on work would be much more
possible at an earlier age and then
there's also the possibility of of
moving topics downward in mathematics
say through sim calc which is teaching
calculus ideas to to middle school
students and for that we'll need
collaborations between scientists
gathering these kinds of data working in
those cutting-edge areas and learning
scientists I'm very pleased to hear so
many projects here having roots in NSF
funding and very grateful that people
are acknowledging that and and realizing
that that we collectively have to
continue to tell that story well because
very often those NSF roots then expand
on into other and interesting app
accomplishments and the NSF piece is not
always so visible but we also face some
challenges and can use your help in
conversation and in going forward in
terms of guiding helping to offer
suggestions to the agency we always
struggle with the balance between very
prescriptive solicitations and open
calls and one wonders whether the kinds
of great accomplishments that we're
hearing about at this meeting have
happened because we've done more of one
or less of the other and so as a funder
how can we how can we make those
decisions well and in particular how can
a grand challenge kind of orientation
which hasn't been very much used in
education at NSF how might something
along those lines be more effective I'm
very intrigued by lots of Tom's ideas
from this morning and we'll be exploring
some of those we also have I think not
been as
as conscientious as we need to be about
the role of instructional practitioners
in the framing of research questions and
we would like to push on that I think a
bit more and then finally all the
questions we've been asking all day the
uptake the scaling the accumulation of
findings what is it that the agency can
help to do to help the field make those
kinds of make progress in those sorts of
areas we have lots of programs that you
all know because you're all funded by
them but I'll give you the list again
that are open to the sorts of the sorts
of projects and the kinds of work that
are being discussed here and so I just
give you this quick list but I do point
out that this list and you can find all
of this of course on the NSF website
this list crosses several directorates
so although the education Directorate is
represented here today our colleagues in
computer science in engineering in the
social sciences and in a variety of
other areas are deeply interested in
questions of learning and so we just
continue to to be grateful to the field
for doing all of the good work that you
do and to be interested in your ideas
about how we can continue to make things
go forward well so thank you very much
right thank you very much for that
really interesting discussion do we have
time for a couple of questions excellent
two I have five questions and I'm not
going to give it all to you right now I
want to ask one quick question I know
people who've worked for large internet
companies which have really thought to
use data to make consumers life better
they're about to do it they get
everything in shape and then they have
to pull it at the last minute because
the consumers are terrified of the
sinister aspects of it and I'm actually
very concerned about the possibility
that we could put a national program in
place to really improve outcomes but
then discover that society isn't ready
for it and you mentioned that in one of
the challenges but I'm interested in
whether you guys have focused on that
question it's a fascinating question
actually I think the only way i can
imagine real progress on that is through
sort of networked interconnected
examples so when that happens locally
when teachers and kids and parents and a
school district figure out a way to make
something improve their there's a great
community support and level of interest
and so if one could imagine some system
of that happening widely you might be
able to build it from the ground up I
can't imagine that some sort of top-down
government government-funded people have
figured out that this is what's best for
you working you know so I just wanted to
add something to that which is some
political scientists have come up with a
notion of deliberative polling and the
premise is that if you just take a
really complicated subject and and ask
someone a bunch of survey questions
you're not you're not likely to get very
informative answers so what they've done
is to say well we're going to take you
know a weekend or a couple days and
we're going to expose people to experts
who have multiple points of views on
this subject and give them some
background reading and give them an
opportunity to grill the experts
and then find out what they think after
this process and that turns out to be
you know a lot more informative than
just calling someone up on the phone and
doing traditional Survey Research so
maybe sort of applying the deliberative
polling methodology to how would you
think about the sort of the issues
associated with on the one hand being
able to harness big data and learning
analytics to create an infrastructure of
continuous improvement to deliver more
personalization on the other hand you
know having a lot more data under
someone's control than people may be
comfortable with now can you say
something about the role in SF plays in
the IRB process and helping universities
understand I mean we do a lot of work
with social network data and just
getting through one university is
problematic and trying to think about
three to four universities collaborating
oftentimes even kills the proposal
before it gets written because of the
everyone that truly understanding what's
possible around big data and IRB right
we've been having a lot of IRB
discussion recently not on this point so
much as we've just come through close
out which is when all of the grants are
going out the door and the questions of
whether all IRB approvals are in order
and in good shape as we're trying to
scramble to get those grants made so
we've been caught up in an operational
question not the more much more
substantive question that you asked but
that's one that has surfaced but not
enough for us to really generate much
internal conversation so maybe we could
chat a little more afterward about how
to do that I when we hear from the field
what the issues are then we're able to
really try to generate either a workshop
aura or some kind of a forum for
bringing those issues up so if I know
what they are a little more detail we
can we can do something with that all
right once again thank you very much for
your
thank you